what we need to achieve out of out of
the industrial election to actually put
an end to it is for the Secretary of
State to come back around the table and
put a better offer on the table for the
hundreds of thousands of nursing staff
but are taking industrial action today
but also that voted in this ballot
Steve Barclay the health Minister says
that the strikes today are are premature
and also disrespectful to the unions who
are getting around the table and and
talking tomorrow
there's certainly no disrespect been
shown from our nursing staff and I can
say that categorically so I would ask
the Secretary of State not to be
disrespectful to those hundreds of
thousands of nursing staff that have
participated in this ballot and that are
losing another day's pay today
standing out on packet line standing up
for a Health Service that's been totally
broken by this government and an NHS in
crisis seven billion plus people in
waiting list all very well rehearsed so
how are we going to address all of those
issues how are we going to address the
tens of thousands of vegan posts that
we've got in England and if we don't
then we will continue with serious risk
to patient safety we'll continue with
those millions of people sitting on
waiting lists and we will never get the
backlog sorted so it really is incumbent
incumbent on this Secretary of State to
get around this table immediately with
myself in the Royal College of Nursing
and put more money I let our nursing
staff get back to do what they want to
do that is care for their patients
what's happening tomorrow we know the
NHS staff Council are going to discuss
this five percent pay offer uh we spoke
to Matthew Taylor from the interest
Confederation an hour ago he said it is
now time he feels for the nurses to
accept the deal
well also listen to the rest of
Matthew's interview and
um his very measured approach and what
he said was that a there would be a
decision made tomorrow but he did say
very clearly that will it address the
120 000 vacant posts that we've got
within the NHS of which forty seven
thousand of those are nursing staff and
I didn't hear him say that that pay
offer would actually address this and
that that was the end to the crisis
we've got in the Health Service because
it won't be it definitely will not be we
need to pay nurses decently and what we
need to see now is the NHS standing up
and being very clear with the government
that they need to address the nursing
crisis that they've got right throughout
the NHS on and until they do so our
nurses unfortunately will be left with
no option but to continue with the
action that they are taking we intend to
rebalot our members again mid-may
without closing date probably mid to for
further action that could say our
nursing staff being pushed out on picket
lines right up until Christmas but we
don't want to do that not a single nurse
dual mate on a picket line today wants
to do that they want to get back into
their work they're selfless people but
we do need to bring this Health Service
back from the brink
what the idea of nurses striking all the
way up until Christmas you've been able
to take the public with you so far do
you not fear that that will change
look the public of England are very
tuned in and I want to say my sincere
thanks to them again this morning every
poll that's carried out by different
organizations show that nursing and the
nursing profession is the most trusted
group in right throughout the UK
and unfortunately I do have to say this
the least trusted people are holding
them back with low pay and per working
conditions and when they hold nursing
back they hold patients back and they
hold the Health Service back so let's
let's now get uh this sorted get paid
talks started again and do the decent
thing for our profession but want to
thank the public because we have stood
by our public through thick and thin
right throughout the pandemic and long
before it and now our public are
standing by us uh we are
um the same side of the the one coin and
we'll continue to stand by our passions
you've paid your demands to to inflation
you know you're obviously going to have
to rebalot members this is going to take
a while inflation's already starting to
come down and it may go up but but most
analysts say that it is going to come
down
um will this then reduce your demands
well I think you've just answered that
question you said it may go up but it
may come down and the payoffer that's on
the table for our nursing staffs five
percent half of what inflation is
sitting at this point in time but what
we see is that the cost of living and
the cost of goods has certainly not come
down and if you speak to any nurse today
or any other day they are seriously
struggling they're desperate to be able
to pay their bills to be able to pay
their rent to be able to pay their child
minding and to put food on the table but
also to be able to travel to work which
is costing more and more for them so we
are really struggling to get people to
work in large cities such as such as
London because the costs are just so so
high earners can't afford to live in the
city and they have to travel for hours
in and ours out after a very long shift
so this has to change by a better
payoffer so that we can retain the most
brilliant nurses that we've got in
England at this time but we need to be
able to attract more people into the
profession and the only way we'll do
that is by paying my decent wage